This isn't a forest.
Not really.
It's actually an urban park
in the densely populated city
of Nanchang, China.
Filled with birds, native trees...
and volcanic rock on 137 acres
of urban land.
It's called a sponge city.
And it's a type of natural infrastructure
that architects around the world
are designing to help us combat and
withstand a changing climate.
So what does it mean for a city
to become spongy?
This video is presented by Delta Airlines.
Today, like everywhere else on the globe
cities are feeling the effects
of climate change.
And they often don't have
the right infrastructure
to help them survive its impacts.
Some neighborhoods in Houston
don't have enough trees
to provide shade and relief
from rising temperatures.
Meanwhile, rising sea levels threaten
coastal cities, like Mumbai and Seoul
that don't often have the infrastructure
to handle more frequent flooding.
This is only made worse
by the fact that cities are covered
with pavement
and other surfaces that
can't absorb water.
Urbanization changes habitat.
So, when you build on a place
it removes vegetation and
alters hydrology.
That's Dr. Charlie Nilon.
He told me that cities play a complicated role
in the climate crisis...
especially when it comes to
maintaining biodiversity.
Biodiversity is, simply put
the total number of plants and animals
that occur someplace.
Biodiversity is one of our main support systems
for human life on earth.
We rely on natural ecosystems
full of diverse plants, animals,
and organisms
for essential things like clean water,
food, and medicine.
And biodiversity is critical
to defending the Earth
against climate change.
We need healthy forests to absorb
carbon dioxide from the air
and enough native plants for pollinators
to help crops flourish.
But studies show that as
urban expansion continues
it can drive habitat losses
that directly put some species in danger...
profoundly impacting global biodiversity.
Cities have a big impact on
what happens locally.
Cities capture a significant number
of plant and animal species...
which are native.
So that, even in cities, there's a significant
amount of biodiversity.
Which means they can play a role in saving
these local plant and animal species.
The really important thing to think about
is not so much how urbanization...
reduces biodiversity, but really
how in cities you can
conserve biodiversity.
One way to do this is by
creating environments
where nature can flourish.
Environments that can also help cities
soak up excess water.
And that's where sponge cities come in.
In 2015, China launched a
sponge city pilot program
in 30 cities across the country.
The goal of the program was
to coordinate
and promote the construction
of sponge cities...
which would improve urban drainage
and flood prevention
and create a diverse biological environment.
Architects did this by supplementing
the existing grey infrastructure
that relied on concrete pipes and dams
with natural solutions like gardens
that are designed to capture rain
and native trees that suck up excess water
through their roots.
In China, these ideas were taken
from ancient drainage systems.
That's because for centuries
Chinese cities actually handled water pretty well
in part because they were built
with nature in mind.
A study from the scientific journal Water
recreated some of these old practices.
Building roofs designed with
sloped eaves allowed rainwater
to fall onto the permeable pavement below...
and exterior walls were lined
with flowers and trees
to absorb rain and stormwater.
Today, natural solutions like these have been
reimplemented in major cities across China.
In Qian’an, a sewage pipe was replaced
with this natural infiltration system...
that uses vegetation beds to purify
storm and rainwater.
Shanghai replaced concrete roads
and sidewalks with this permeable pavement
which is lined with vegetation
to absorb excess water
into the soil underground.
And across Wuhan, dozens of
urban gardens like these
were planted to absorb water before
it overwhelms communities.
Most of these projects rely on
introducing vegetation
in an urban area to soak up excess water.
This is a really great way to handle flooding
and it also supports urban biodiversity.
Because you're providing habitat for additional groups...
Plant and animal species.
Sometimes you can restore habitats
that have been lost.
Despite these benefits, sponge cities
can't fix everything.
The connection between
climate change and flooding
is still being studied.
But when floods do happen
these spongy cities are only able
to absorb excess water
up to a certain point.
In 2021, sponge city designs in
Zhengzhou failed
when historic rainfall drenched the city.
More than 300 people died from
the catastrophic flooding.
There are other limitations, too.
One review of sponge cities in
Guian New District
found that national standards and codes
for spongy infrastructure
are really difficult to enforce
because climate, hydrology,
and even socio-economics
are vastly different from one city to the next.
So what might work in some cities
won't necessarily
solve climate-related problems
in others.
Plus, ambitious sponge city designs
like the sprawling parks
built in China
are expensive and require a lot of space...
which most cities don't have.
So some US cities experimenting
with natural infrastructure
like LA  and Boston
are using the green space
they already have.
By trying things like planting
vegetation on curbs...
and creating green spaces
along median strips.
One type of city design
certainly won't save us
from climate change...
but they can make a difference
in how we live with it.
We often talk about biodiversity
like it's far away, but it's actually
right there.
And I think the more that people
understand that
the kinds of things they do around
where they live
that really matters.
People can do things to change cities.
They can do things
to make cities different.
to make cities better.